[Music]
welcome to this is hard to believe it's
it's session number forty the worlds of
speculative fiction series and it's kind
of nice that we're doing analyst Huxley
for that in part because his works are
you know they're not huge and demanding
I would say we'll talk about style and
in a bit but it's also you know you know
kind of a nice capstone I I'd say for
all the stuff that we've done both of
you have been coming for a very long
time so so I think we'll have a
interesting conversation about this so I
picked these three works brave new world
of course you can't not do that this is
probably the most famous work and that
island is sort of a companion piece in
many respects and I've got some
interesting things to bring up about his
motivation for writing it
if brave new world is a dystopia island
as a utopia and then we've got a bin
essence which is also a dystopia but a
different sort of dystopia and and
there's you know he's got other works
where there's utopian themes running
through them but I thought these three
would be good companion pieces because
you know the more I was reading about
him and and the interests that he had
and the commitments that he made in
terms of politics and and you could call
it the history of ideas you know as it's
developing in our century or the last
century the more it became clear that
that one of the absolutely central
preoccupation of him was charting out
where we might be going and what the
great threats to human freedom and
human development and democracy were and
so I thought ape in essence kind of you
know works for that as well
so as usual I've got a I've got a
timeline for us and I've got some some
passages that I thought were
particularly interesting Huxley really
you know that so the the series is
philosophical themes in speculative
fiction Huxley is essentially a
philosopher in a very broad sense and
that was actually one of the themes that
I wanted to talk about so before we I
thought before we go into all the usual
stuff I would just sort of launch into
that idea you know we often think of
philosophy as this academic discipline
which which it is I mean you go down the
road and you know UW Madison as a nice
department there and so does Marquette
and so does UWM and you know smaller
schools do as well
and there's sort of a you know a Canon
of academic philosophy there's different
ways of doing it but philosophy has
always been much more than just what
gets taught as as philosophy proper if
you know to take the academic thing if
you wanted to study say Alexis de
Tocqueville great French social theorist
who's a philosopher the work that he's
doing is framed as philosophy you
wouldn't find him usually in a
philosophy department you'd have to go
to a political science department or if
you want to read some of the you know
20th century French thinkers like say
Rolen bards probably they're not going
to teach you or dari dot or you know
people like that they're probably going
to get taught in a an English department
or are gonna literary studies or
something like that and philosophy has
all these connections with you know
sociology and psychology and you know
political science history really all the
humanities and
and a lot of philosophy ends up getting
done outside of philosophy departments
where it's a bit more rarefied you could
say and I think they they sometimes take
that as the norm Huxley isn't like that
at all he is he's just as concerned with
understanding what was going on and what
he thought was actually right about
Freud I mean by Freudianism per se he
engages with BF Skinner who was quite
quit big at the time he talks about the
you know what the Russians were doing
not just in terms of Pavlov's
experiments which were kind of a small
scale actually but in terms of social
conditioning in the Soviet republic and
and all sorts of other things in terms
of psychology talks about market
research vance's the hidden persuaders I
wanna either of you remember that book
from the 50s or the 60s but it was
looking at how advertisers are using
depth psychology to sell products he's
looking at all of that sort of stuff and
then he'll he'll bring up other people
like John Dewey or Herbert Spencer or
the utilitarians or you know there was
this it really wasn't anybody who he
wasn't willing to bring to the table as
worthy of participating in the
conversation for whatever topic it was
he also was quite interested in you know
non-western philosophy particularly
Indian philosophy Hinduism and my and my
on a Buddhism primarily and that was at
a time when there wasn't an awful lot of
that so so I think that he's he's kind
of a cool guy just because he
exemplifies one one image of what a
philosopher could be this very broad
well well-read willing to engage with
you know
he is coming from all different places
so long as they have importance and and
you can't be that way within academic
philosophy and it's a Alistair McIntyre
who just recently celebrated his 90th
birthday best known for his book after
virtue but he done you know decades of
work before that exemplifies that as
well he people don't know this but he
worked as sometimes as a consultant to
business you know organizations trying
to help them to better understand what
was going on with their workplaces
because he was interested in how people
actually lived and and what would what
would conduce to human happiness and you
know if you look back over the history
of philosophy the people who we we now
consider grades they weren't these
narrow restricted Minds either I mean
Jeremy Bentham if you've ever read any
of his stuff it's rather dry but he he
like breeds everybody and talks about
everybody Rene Descartes same way
Aristotle of course had less to draw on
his time but he doesn't just say oh I'm
only gonna look at the Philosopher's
he's willing to engage of playwrights
and yeah yeah I mean he he thinks that
everybody who has something to
contribute should be should be brought
into the proverbial conversation so I
thought that was kind of cool about
Huxley and I'd never really realized
that until I started doing some of this
this research him I always thought I was
kind of you know he's the guy who wrote
in a brave new world and actually taught
or well for for a semester apparently it
was a terrible teacher terribly
disorganized the students don't remember
anything remember and none of them of
course remember anything now they're all
dead they didn't remember anything good
about him other than he seemed
passionate about his subjects so so we
launched in through the biography
he's a turn-of-the-century baby you
could say born in 1894 he was born into
this this kind of famous family that had
already
had a sort of splash and British letters
his mom dies pretty young cancer there's
actually a lot of cancer as I started
going through the history a lot of
cancer in his his life he has an eye
disease which leaves him send me blind
that'll also keep him from serving in
World War one it never goes in ever he
never fully recovers his eyesight the
one thing that's a little less reputable
he does get involved with I forget the
name of this this sort of crank heal
your own heal your eyes through
exercises kind of their kind of method
and he tries to say that it actually
works but it doesn't really work but you
know he's he's a you know he's spending
quite a lot of time trying to learn
things he starts writing pretty young
nineteen sixteen is his first set of
poems is published he tries to give him
the army they turn him down they say we
can't use you and you know things were
pretty bad by then so if they were
turning him down his eyesight was pretty
bad and he begins editing Oxford poetry
he graduates from from Oxford at that
time works at this place called gars
Anton Manor which was worth us the smart
set though they call the Bloomsbury set
or group was this included people like
Alfred North Whitehead and Bertrand
Russell and he's doing basically menial
work you know you can think of it sort
of like people working at a country club
and getting to meet rich people you know
or like when I was in college the big
place that the people wanted to work
when I cuz I was in Sheboygan was the
American Club up in Kohler and they
would make contacts right you know the
contacts were never actually gonna be
followed up but these rich people would
talk to you about their their ideas
you know treat you as semi-human for you
know why would ask you to go get them
gin and tonic or whatever and he'll
actually he'll he'll Lampoon them in his
first novel chrome yellow then he's
invited by this guy John Middleton
Murray to join the staff of the
Athenaeum this new this literary
magazine that had been around for a
while and then kind of fallen on hard
times they're reorganizing it and then
so he does that by then he's you know
publishing more works these are all
poetry for the most part early on he
gets married to this woman Maria nice
they have a son soon after that Matthew
and in 1921 he publishes his first novel
chrome yellow and in his early career
known as a satirist so he's I guess you
could say it's sort of like an evil and
wah sort of character right look at
these rich people and their crazy
foibles and the way they think about
things he's not writing you know utopian
or dystopian novels it's more the who's
screwing who who's who's drunk all the
time I don't there's got to be a name
for that that job what's up usually yeah
but this is like this isn't attempting
to say well things are as bad as they
could possibly get it's just you know
here's what the the smart set is doing
and you know eventually I'm not sure
about the year because nobody actually
has the proper year for this but he
works at this Brunner and moaned this
chemical plant and billing up and that's
part of the germ for brave new world he
sees how this plant is organized and how
you know you can get so much out of the
workers if you you know if you apply
these these modern scientific management
techniques and he starts writing you
know quite a bit more so by the late 20s
he's writing novels that you could say
have a bit more weight to them
and a lot more he's writing more essays
and things like that and then 1932 brave
new worlds probably his most important
work I would say certainly the one he's
best known for it's been voted like one
of the top 100 novels of the 20th
century and so that's 1932 that's kind
of interesting because when you read it
I remember reading it in high school I
would have never guessed it was written
in 1932 I would have thought it was
written much later
did you have the same impression yeah I
didn't know when I read it first high
school or college I didn't know when it
was real did you think it was a grit
later than it turned out to be real yeah
I think so why I don't know why for me
well in my case I was in college in the
60s yeah high school early 60s and even
then there was discussion about
artificial intelligence and robots and
yeah mechanization and automated lines
in the factories yeah you know that sort
of thing so that was there was an
awareness of that with union
negotiations of what have you so that
was in the out there in the SS out there
being talked about
yeah and scientific advancements of
where we were going so so yeah it
sounded contemporary okay yeah oh yeah I
had the same sort of there hasn't well
of course it probably was written in the
60s that's what I thought I mean he was
he's dead by the middle 60s so well I
was thought as a companion piece almost
- it's a 1984 no oh no - hindlimbs book
Oh interesting draw a blank right now in
the name
the title our utopian novel yeah it was
uh I'll think about it
I think yeah but it was one of Highlands
greats what his bid was and they so I
thought it came out around the same time
that would make sense yeah so I'll look
it up okay well so continuing on with
this he meets be achieved morons down in
Italy and eventually when Lawrence dies
he had its Lawrence's letters as sort of
a gesture of friendship and then you
know he's continuing to publish he'll
move to Los Angeles and and that's kind
of an interesting step for him in 1937
and then he gets really involved with
the movie industry as a matter of fact
he collaborated oh yeah I mean is that a
it's yeah but is it a utopian novel
you've got a character who is it was
more dystopian than it was utopian in
some ways yeah you got a character who
is out of touch just like John is right
because he's because he's you know from
from a different place mm-hmm
so you've got the character he's being
shown around so there is some of that
yeah yeah it's the same kind of one
person's not the same as the society he
suddenly dropped into yeah okay I saw
them in Canadian pieces yeah yeah not
parallel but sort of in the same vein
yeah and stranger estranged land was
published in 61 yeah so they had kind of
the same feel which would cause you to
think they were written in ya rotten
yeah maybe even by people who knew each
other but of course they didn't
that's very interesting I mean I don't
know that Huxley and Heinlein never met
I didn't see anything about that but I
mean Huxley was in the United States
from the 30s onward in Los Angeles so
who knows but yes so he started working
for Metro gold admire and he does some
script writing I got the so he works on
Pride and Prejudice
he works on Madame Curie Jane Eyre
a woman's vengeance prelude to fame and
that Disney brings him in to work on the
Alice in Wonderland really and he did
that he doesn't get credited for it but
he you know apparently had a good rep in
the industry and and he's mostly doing
script writing you know which makes
sense because a lot of the script
writers back then were novelists or
other you know other people who had a
literary background I mean he seems to
be somebody who had a really good knack
for organization so he's not something
sorta like some poet who doesn't know
anything about anything who they can't
get any work at it this guy knows how to
work so in any case you know time goes
on he wins James Tait black Memorial
Prize eventually the NBC university
theater does a radio adaptation of after
many a summer which is which is kind of
interesting thing and then Orwell writes
1984 and or well as I'd mentioned had
been his student briefly many writes his
his former students and I this isn't the
whole letter but it's it's an
interesting part of it so he says may I
speak instead of the thing which which
the book deals the ultimate revolution
the first hints of philosophy of the
ultimate revolution the revolution which
lies beyond politics and economics and
which aims at total subversion of the
individual psychology and physiology are
found in the mark you decide who
regarded himself as the continued ater
summative Robespierre and Babu the
philosophy of that ruling minority or
you know that was often called the
Vanguard theory right in communist
circles the philosophy of the ruling
minority in 1984 is a sane ISM which has
been carried to its logical conclusion
by going beyond sex and denying it
whether in actual fact the policy of the
boot on the face can go on and
definitely seems doubtful
so he's criticizing Orwell here a little
bit
my own belief is that the ruling
oligarchy will find less arduous and
wasteful ways of governing and
satisfying its lust for power and these
ways will resemble those which I
described in brave new world within the
next generation I believe that the
world's rulers will discover that infant
conditioning and narco-hypnosis are more
efficient as instruments of government
than clubs and prisons and that lust for
power can be just as completely
satisfied by suggesting people into
loving their servitude as by flogging
and kicking them into obedience in other
words I feel that the nightmare of 1984
is destined to modulate into the
nightmare of a world having more
resemblance to that which I imagine in
brave new world the change will be
brought about as a result of a felt need
for increased efficiency meanwhile of
course there may be a large-scale
biological and atomic war in which case
we shall have nightmares of other and
scarcely imaginable kinds and that
that's what ape and essence right is is
dealing with those sorts of catastrophic
futures so it's kind of an interesting
thing I mean he's saying to his student
yeah you know you've got to stop it
right in a way and there's a lot of
stuff around here that really does
resemble what you're talking about it
seems to be heading in that direction
but doesn't it seem to you like you know
there's there's kind of a law of
diminishing returns almost you know
sheer force and terror so they often get
counterpoise with each other
oh yeah okay because that is a world
where a nuclear war is in the past yeah
yeah but they created an experiment
where people are are divided into castes
and so there there's subservient by
being told this is how you are yeah it's
uh it's that issue of differentiation of
humankind I mean Plato Plato brings it
up in the Republic and the basic idea is
well different people are have different
aptitudes why shouldn't we let them do
what they're naturally fitted for and
then divergent you have to do like
discover and choose right well you have
to choose
yeah so presumably you you don't choose
like out of you know well I just today I
feel like this you you you the choice is
a good choice sixteen years yeah yeah
choose rather than somebody choosing for
you but you don't get to try it out and
see yeah once you choose you're kind of
screwed you're locked in yeah and like
the castes and brave new world you're a
choice yeah but epsilon or epsilon Delta
sir TOPAS yeah and in diversion there
once you're in that group
here's that's it yeah you are that and
you're expected to live under those
under the north under those norms yeah
yeah yeah yeah I mean and in 1984 there
is a I suppose a sort of a a class
system right but it's more just like the
elites everybody else yeah the masses
and things are pretty crappy I mean
there are the people under the elites
who do the work of the elites yeah
follow orders yeah is that almost
military care
yeah you know it's interesting Russo
he wrote quite a few works that had to
do with like how civilization is is you
know damaging to our nature and stuff
like that and part of what he didn't
like was the hierarchy that was involved
in civilization which shouldn't be based
on virtue but inevitably winds up being
based instead on wealth power and social
status
all three are rather arbitrary and he
said you know one of the key questions
you got to ask yourself is well why
would somebody who's not at the top why
would they tolerate this this nonsense
right Andrew so the answer is you're
happy being in the middle because you
can kick down on somebody else and so
long as you've got somebody else for you
can like have lower than you you're cool
with that you know most likely I mean
there'll be some some people who are
like no I reject that you know I'm not
gonna put up with that but most people
will according to Rousseau go along with
it and then I guess in 1984 that's part
of what's what's going on in you know in
brave new world is more like well we're
all one big happy family you know well
didn't have a form to or will did it oh
yeah
they even in brave new world yes I'm
animals are more equal than others well
in the deterioration of the society to
where the animals yeah some animals gain
more power than others it becomes very
1984 like yeah no boxer I think was the
name of the horse wasn't he yeah
yeah that was one of the saddest parts
about it I remember listening to 1984
with Katherine and she was maybe four or
five years old we're listening to her
drive
yeah that's a Hamel farm yeah and when
boxer dies it was very hard for both of
us you know because he gets so screwed
you know he constantly taken advantage
of and he's one of the few good good
characters in the story yeah so he just
in even a braking role actually does it
with the alphas because the alphas are
clearly everybody else is below them and
then ya see them that way and they want
to keep them down yeah well you even the
betas are kind of jerks and the babies
yeah they don't want to Minneapolis they
don't they make it clear that they tried
that and it didn't work
yeah so they don't want too many office
boy you know this is like almost totally
off topic but there was a really
interesting I think it's a Henry Kutner
story called the marching morons either
you ever read it
yeah so in it there's a guy who's a
salesman and he's not he's not super
bright
he's just average intelligence and he
somehow gets frozen in stasis for like
200 years and when they dig him up the
person who digs him up is actually from
this this hyper intelligent cast of
people who actually run the entire world
Society there's not that many of them
because the rest of the world are just
morons like idiots and they all you can
do with them is like keep them busy at
there's stupid BS jobs that don't do
anything you give them cars where you
know the you know the speedometer says
they're going 200 miles an hour but
they're only going 40 so they feel like
they're going fast and at one point in
time the intelligent people so you know
the race is set separated itself out
right functionally at one time the
manager class tried to just let all
these stupid people die and the stench
the chaos was so terrible that within
two weeks they're like we can't do this
so the salesman who is not as
intelligent as these other people he he
comes up with a scheme they're gonna all
go to colonize other planets and so what
they do is they take a a bunch of
rockets and they load up people from an
entire city onto those Rockets and they
should have been to the Sun and say
they're going on a trip you know they
don't know where the trip is but they
just know it's someplace really great
and then they take all the metal from
that city and they turn it into new
rockets and eventually you know they
send and send them into the Sun and they
do this through the entire population to
get rid of all the morons and then he
gets put in the last rocket but you know
maybe ask like well what would a society
like that be for the people that are
involved so it's they're all like alphas
from the brave new world perspective
they're all like super intelligent
capable confident I mean it could be
really nice or it could really be
terrible because can people like that
actually get along if they don't have
people underneath them to take care of
things I don't know you know okay I
think they've probably developed new
strats oh okay yeah like using this
range in this range you're the super
smart people yeah those are just smart
you have any chance to do that ya know
the smart people get to wash your
clothes yeah humanity tends to divide
and separate yeah it just seems to be
built into her do you know make tribes
yeah yeah we do that you know so the
like a super powerful super smart thing
like that reminds me of the Babylonian a
new metal ish which is this
you know it's an alternate Mesopotamian
origin story for Humanity and for the
cosmos right and it's celebrating Marv
do you know who is probably like the you
know the most important god of that city
and what ends up happening and it long
story short is you know the the powerful
god Marduk and the other gods destroyed
Tiamat and I think it's a spoon and all
that these ancient things it's sort of
like the you know the ancient Greek
Olympian gods just the Titans sort of
story but what there's there's a human
creation story in it and they the gods
are all there and the gods are like well
who's gonna be in charge and who's gonna
take orders and so the solution to this
is make human beings and human beings
could be slaves of the gods that way
every single God can hand his or her own
little like place where they're in
charge and if they have to take crap
from the God above them it's okay
because they they've got all these no
exactly
so they take the blood of the one of the
defeated gods and they they mix it with
you know dirt and make human beings and
it says explicitly explicitly in their
human beings are created to be slaves of
the gods
you know it's you know you contrast that
to the biblical creation story you know
again dirt but breath is you know
breathed into it and there's nothing
like well you're you're God's slave now
instead it's you know named the animals
go forth and multiply
don't eat that treaty you know that sort
of business so yeah maybe there maybe
there's a fundamental recurring dynamic
like that
[Music]
Church yeah and looked at teleclass on
the denomination's nominations and how
we learn from yeah belief system to
thousands of different approaches oh
yeah and my favorite example is there's
a museum in Ohio a Mennonite Museum
about the development of Amish and
Mennonite Anabaptist branch right well
no they're not a my Baptist actually
there's something a little different
there yeah yeah but there's I was
walking around this museum and went into
a side room yeah and here are these
cases of bonnets my Amish bonnets oh
yeah and how this group broke from this
group because they thought this bonnet
was not modest enough yeah and this
group's broke from this group because
they wanted their bonnets to have a
little decoration and this group broke
from this group because I spawn it it
was like over bonnets they split yeah
any differentiating feature any
differentiating fish you manatee seems
to be hardwired to differentiate there's
actually going so going back to the like
world of brave new world I mean it's a
world of consumerism right and one of
the interesting things and market
research is what's called marginal
differentiation which means that a
product doesn't have to be fundamentally
different it just has to be different
enough to make people feel like they're
they're experiencing something new and
it you know it's a way of expressing
their own identity so you can like go in
the gas station and you know all those
like keychains and knickknacks and all
that garbage that they have up by the
front you know yes so who buys that that
crap well people who want to express
their individuality with you know a name
like a keychain that has their fingers
whatever it is
their name maybe you know their favorite
beer and it's all just like
mass-produced crap you know but but
people people can invest that with their
their emotions and feel like the
Phillies for a little while that's me
you know I bought teaching last
Christmas for our little boys okay sort
of yeah it said they never have my name
oh yeah it's funny but it's about naming
my name there is my identity there he
can identify with the people who also
get the their dad money
thank you yeah he's sort of the
miscellaneous category you know I
thought brave new world was less about
consumerism but I thought it was more
about leveling things okay getting rid
of the conflict getting rid of and you
had to you have to you have to lose
individuality or lose independent
thought and creativity yeah in order to
trade that for a form of pacifism a form
of we have no conflict we've eliminated
comma interesting yes so it's a you know
Huxley himself was a pacifist because
when they talk but this is this we store
like a bad kind of past yeah we talk
about the experiment of the island with
all alphas yeah the issue was that there
was conflict yep because they're all
assertive and and they got their own
idea doing all this to eliminate
conflict yeah peace in this that makes
me think of a I went into other a very
high-end store not my usual yeah deal
and and I know it's my own perspective
but almost to a person I felt like other
people in the store all thought they
were better than the people at Pro
because they would they would walk in
front of someone they'd cut people off
the
dismissive everyone around them in my my
head I'm thinking you all think you're
the most important person right now yeah
and the only person who doesn't feel
that way because this is not my you know
I was in I was at a conference in
Chicago one time at the lumen christi
institute and it's at the university of
chicago it's very well funded and all
that and so there's like this this talk
that's given and then people are out you
know kind of milling around talking
about something and there was a guy
there he was I don't he was from some
some Ivy you know University and he was
talking about something having to do
with 20 early 20th century French
Catholic thinkers and I sort of broke in
and I said well that's not actually
right you know this this guy did this
cuz I was then that was one of my areas
of research and he like looked at me and
then the thing that was really funny as
he said to me who are you and I said oh
I'm Greg Sadler and they said no no I
mean who are you you know where where
are you teaching you know what's your
status exactly because he figured if
somebody like had something to say they
must obviously be from a good University
like his own I looked at him and that I
said I'm a nobody you wouldn't know
where I'm from you know I just happen to
know about this stuff because this is
what I what I researched and you know my
experience coming from lower to your
institutions and dealers a lot of people
from elite institutions is the elites
don't actually know more than the rest
of us they're just better connected and
they have that sort of natural that's
it's not natural it's learned this
attitude of superiority that then lets
them kind of push through you know
they're less worried about breaking
rules because they observe to break the
rules you know where does the rest of us
are like
you know I don't know and you know they
don't suffer from impostor syndrome we
do but there's no reason for us to
because we usually know our stuff you
know and and some of the time they're
just kind of flimflamming through but
now in brave new world there is I mean
the alphas really are an elite you know
in 1984 they're an elite because they're
ruthless I guess you know I got the
impression that Nady 1984 anybody could
become part of the party yeah right yeah
you didn't you'd have to be willing to
use force and buy into whatever the
party says yeah McCarthyism two-degree
yeah I think I remember it's McCarthyism
because McCarthy was more like you know
that's rabid fear of communism huh right
but he's also it was his ego yeah true
he wanted to do you want to be important
more important so that was a piece of it
yeah yeah well are you sneaking off they
asked the thing you're talking about in
terms that we're talking about in terms
of people thinking they're better you
see that play out in racism you see it
play out
elation ISM you know I mean you can you
can see it in a lot of different things
yeah I mean that's another thing if you
have a utopia like brave new world which
is really it's supposed to be a dystopia
one way of overcoming things like racism
which is a very arbitrary you know way
of dividing people up well you just say
that that none of that stuff matters
skin color doesn't matter
I think origin doesn't matter
it's like a brave new world the lower
castes were black skinned or the green
skinned red skinned that way
no white okay I mean one of the other
things that's in the brave new world to
voters and they were Dwarfs all work
dwarf yeah true yeah as I was driving
over I was thinking about like the
treatment of women in in brave new world
you know it's supposed to happen like
way in the future you look at like you
know things are not where they ought to
be today but they're a lot more equal
than they used to be Andy and I were
just talking about how like when she
goes to the the Wisconsin Athletic Club
and she's like observing the different
people there if some some young women
are who often don't wear all that much
are like walking by it's it's mostly
like the 60 to 70 year old men who are
like openly leering at them right now
maybe that the 40 year olds are actually
like surreptitiously looking as well
right but there's been this this change
where it's like hey that's that's not
cool that's kind of you know gross old
man behavior knock it off you know and I
would think that I like by you know
whatever for your fort were in and in
brave new world you know you've got guys
doing locker room talking they're
bragging about because their men are
talking about having three women on
their lap yeah and and so I mean we
could say well that maybe that's a
product of huxley not imagining well
enough what ingenuous quality would be
like yeah I mean if Rainer Maria Rilke
were writing it which I mean he didn't
write that he wrote a few other novels
and mostly poetry women would have a
completely different status and in
whatever utopia he were presenting I
think because he saw that as a genuine
problem and he said there's a lot of
people kind of scared about what's
happening with the sexes in our time
you know women are gonna you turn into
something different
and we don't know what it's going to be
but they're going to be freer and in
doing so men will also become freer in
the process or Mary Wollstonecraft had
written that you know I think women
would have a different status as well
that's true that's just terrible for
everybody yeah I think that's right yeah
yeah so I don't think I need to go with
over anymore the biography but let's
let's look at some of the other things
that he had to say so one of the
passages that I have in here from brave
new world revisited which is like a set
of essays that he wrote so the 1931 a
brave new world was being written I was
convinced there was still plenty of time
the completely organized society the
scientific caste system abolition of
free will by methodical conditioning
servitude made acceptable by regular
doses of chemically induced happiness
the orthodoxies drummed in by Knightly
courses of sleep teaching all these are
features of the world these were coming
all right but not my time not even the
time of my grandchildren they said we
who are living in the second quarter of
the 20th century ad were the inhabitants
of a gruesome kind of universe but the
nightmare of those Depression years is
radically different from the nightmare
of the future described in brave new
world ours was a nightmare of too little
order there's of too much and I think
that's that's kind of an interesting
point he talks about over organization
uses that term quite a lot in that essay
he says 27 years later I feel a good
deal less optimistic than when I was
writing
brave new world the prophecy is made in
31 are coming true much sooner than I
thought they would the Blessed interval
between two little order and the
nightmare of too much has not yet begun
and shows an old sign of beginning in
the West it's true individual men and
women as individual men and women still
enjoy a large measure of freedom but
even those countries that have a
tradition of democratic government the
freedom and the desire for this freedom
seems to be on the wane and the rest of
the world freedom for individuals has
already gone or is manifestly about to
go and so he thinks that there's there's
a you know good chance for something
like what he's talking about a brave new
world to start happening and so that
that's a good you know launch into some
of these other themes that I wanted to
talk about one is he's concerned about
technology and one of the types of
technology that he's discussing in this
and also in the island is pharmaceutical
technology drugs that can change the way
we feel what we you know do or don't do
how we respond to things and it's good
to point out to Huxley himself
experimented a bit with mescaline and
with I think with LSD as well he talks
about mescaline and the doors and
perception and he was very interested in
what what effects drugs could handle on
people so soma and brave new world is
this this drug that you know you start
feeling anxious and have some soul moan
you know you start feeling like maybe
life doesn't have meaning has some so
much it's it's a doesn't have any bad
side effects for the most part and you
can just numb yourself to all the crappy
stuff that's going on so it's especially
among the lower classes they get to
think it's paraded to you know the
atmosphere they riot
and you know there's there's a lot of
this drugging up of people even shows up
on the savage reservation what Linda's
taking this call yeah yeah now in the
the island they have the moksha drug
which is sort of like the I mean the
island is a is a genuine utopia although
it fails in the end because they can't
defend themselves militarily and they
can't deal with the the new Raja who's
been formed outside of their their
society but they've got this this drug
that opens up perception which seems
much like like what he described
masculine as it's being and so the idea
there is that that's sort of if we think
about drugs not as just drugs but we
think of them as a kind of technology
what does the technology do it enables
us to modify the external world or to
modify the internal world and you know
if you think about our society and you
know you might want to chime in here
about you know therapy and the
psychiatric establishment and stuff like
that we've really moved away in large
part from from talk therapy to you know
since the really from the 50s and 60s
but especially in the 80s and 90s into
prescribing psychotropic drugs for
pretty much any sort of ailment that
people have and and oftentimes not as a
part of their therapy but as the main
integral component right I would
disagree I mean we just think we do have
a few types of talk therapy at CBT we
have more drug therapies because we now
know more about the physical the
physiological cause of mental illness
some of it we do some of that we're just
still experimenting yeah we are and and
and very often when a person gets
prescribed say any antidepressants it's
very rare that they actually get blood
work done to determine whether there's a
you know a real need for for it in terms
of brain chemistry or anything like that
well detect yeah yeah we know from
research that there are certain things
that impact the brain yeah we know now
more about those physiological chemicals
that's that's quite true yeah and we
know that there are certain drugs that
can help with that
yeah so they prescribe them we
automatically yeah and we often assume
that the brain stuff is the brain
chemistry is all that's happening so
like depression is a great example
there's a really nice book out there
called lost connections
I think is last name it's Hari and you
know he was one of these people who
suffered from depression was told
there's something wrong with your brain
you need to be on antidepressants and
you know they'd make him feel good for a
while and then they you know they'd wear
off and the effects wouldn't last and
then he'd be depressed again and he was
never exposed to the idea that
depression could also have correlates in
other things like negative self-talk
which CBT focuses a or in your
connection so this book is called lost
connections because it's about all these
different modalities of connection that
the people can easily lose oftentimes
through trauma like connection to their
own body a connection to the
environment connection to other people
and you know some cases yeah some people
definitely need drugs well you know I've
got an uncle who's severely bipolar and
if he doesn't have drugs he can't
function but there's a lot of people who
the drug can help as a sort of a
temporary fix and then they if they work
on themselves I have depression yeah and
experience is always a combination of
therapy talk therapy and drug yeah I
know I do thank you - not one or the
other and I've experienced sometimes
talk therapy and drug and often times
let's give you drugs yeah I mean I think
there's like a wide range and sometimes
you know I remember in the 1990s
gynecologists started prescribing
antidepressants - today well and to
girls girls and there wasn't any like
work up or anything like that we carried
out this massive I mean nowadays we
could actually if we if we compiled all
the data if people kept good records
which is probably not the case we could
probably figure out what the effects of
antidepressants were girls and
developing brains and what the effect of
large doses of Ritalin our male rings
yeah
because they were over prescribed for
both yeah very easily no it's it's not
like 1980 it's sound like a brave new
world because there's no there's no
systematic attempt to do it it was more
to sort of like a patchwork of well this
person prescribes a lot this person
doesn't you know we did run into with
ritalin we do do have a pattern
yeah where a lot of teachers and a lot
of parents jump to that yeah yeah two
children that were unruly and some of
them started taking the route Allu
themselves
jump to it is an easy solution yeah many
teachers of parents and I know somebody
who the first child needed it yeah
her second child was just an active boy
and she gave it to him also yeah because
it was less trouble yeah and so you saw
that while I think it's gotten better
yeah it's probably Canada again like a
patchwork it's probably better in some
places and then just as bad in other
places brave new world isn't it also a
human tendency just wanna make life
easier yes that's the scene in politics
people who don't vote it's like okay
just let somebody else yeah yeah let
someone else decide I've actually heard
Millennials who said you know whatever
whatever whatever is gonna happen it's
gonna happen I know I disagree well but
then I also happened with you know my
generation Generation X a lot of them
didn't vote when they are like in the 18
to 24 year old category as well and then
they started voting once they they got
older and started realizing they better
you know it might be it might be a youth
thing it's hard to get them they
actually took now I know a lot of
seniors that didn't vote in the last
couple elections oh really that's
unusual
that's that's an interesting development
why oh no because they didn't think they
had a good choice mm-hmm
and rather not vote yeah and let it fall
where it may yeah they vote and be
voting for somebody who didn't want to
vote for it yeah so I had a lot of I
knew a lot of seniors who the last two
elections didn't vote interesting I know
I had a conversation back in the night
and the 2000s with somebody who was a
big advocate of principled non vote
and the idea was he was he was a
Catholic social theorist and he said
listen
neither the Democratic Party nor the
Republican Party follows anything
remotely like what an authentic
following of Catholic social doctrine
would require so you can't vote for the
Democrats for these reasons you also
can't vote for the Republicans for these
reasons this is like during the the
George Bush era and I said well that's
okay I can understand that
but nobody knows that your principle not
voting is any different than some guy
who'd just overslept you know it's not
like you're you're checking off a box
that says neither these are any good you
know and it gets tallied anywhere you
know and that's one of the that's one of
the fundamental problems with it you
know it may as well just be I'd rather
drink or you know something like that
coming back to the technology thing so
so pharmaceuticals are a a kind of
technology that can change you know
Francis Fukuyama had a really
interesting book he's the guy who's
famous for the end of history thesis
after you know he wrote this book in the
1990s called the end of history and the
last man because you know the Soviet
Union had collapsed that it looked like
you know liberal democracies and
capitalism was the way everything was
going sure there was la McMillan tense
and you know there's countries like Iran
and you know there's there's also also
countries that are economically
capitalist but not not liberal
democracies like Singapore and China's
rising but for the most part it's gonna
be you know it's gonna be liberal
democracy and capitalism going forward
right
that was the optimism of the 90s and
then we quit paying attention everything
and and what do you know
so he said history is ended meaning
there are no like new things to come on
the scene like fascism or communism or
you know anything to present a real yeah
so he got he got turned down a lot for
that right and rightly so but he wrote
another book at the 2000s called our
post human future where he was talking
about the pharmaceutical industry and
what you know what were the implications
of all this over prescribing we don't we
you know we're not quite sure what it's
going to do but it's going to lead to
different a different structuring of
society because it isn't technology it
allows us to modify things and then you
know you can think about organizational
technology and in brave new world that's
it's mostly having to do with like you
know the groups that people are in and
test-tube babies and things like that
but you know we have our own
organizational technology the modern
corporation is a a form of community
that you know the people who are within
it and have power exercised over them
often you know have all sorts of things
sort of done to them that determine
where they're going and we now have
these you know the four largest market
cap countries right now are the tech
countries ten tech that's a slip tech
companies not tech countries but they
may as well be coming yeah yeah so I you
know Amazon Facebook Google Microsoft
and
Apple yeah so the big five and then of
the top ten some of the other ones are
actually foreign tech companies like
Alibaba that we kind of fly under our
radar because we don't we don't pay
close attention to that but they're part
of the global marketplace that Foxconn
well Foxconn is just a small little blip
in that sort of looks sort of like
Twitter is or things like that they have
if they have a significant market of
capitalization but not like these
massive things and and each one of them
has the the you know each one of them
winds up with these grandiose hubris
stick plans like Google is going to
change our life Apple is going to change
our life you know and then they try to
undercut each other and supply the same
sort of things that each other can can
do and and their you know I mean you
think about like the whole idea of the
Internet of Things and that we should
have you know all of these things in
here with cameras everywhere that sounds
like a terrible idea to me but but but
that's what they're they're really
pushing and if we have brave new world
at our time it's probably not going to
be because of the government it's
probably going to be because these
companies end up having so much all
ready have so much power I recently
you're actually with Apple I cancelled
my Apple account oh oh interest that's
because I'm not a big apple I have
common stockholders okay I don't have a
lot of Apple products yeah but I had an
iPod okay and so I had iTunes on my
computer and I think I know where this
is going I went in one day yeah and
music that I had loaded to my computer
from CDs I had chest was gone was gone
yep it had disappeared yeah so I
contacted them and finally got ahold of
somebody and he couldn't explain it
except no maybe with an update he got
wiped out and yeah that's not much of an
explanation when I questioned it
said well you don't really old music we
own it yeah we our relationship is not
with you our relationship is with the
artists yeah we have no relationship
with you and we will do whatever we
choose well music professionally honest
horrified profession it's like they were
there that that happened like a couple
years ago they made that transition and
there were a lot of artists who were
doing original work and they had their
stuff on their computers and their mp3s
got sucked up into the cloud and then
Apple thou had them and sometimes just
got rid of them altogether you know
unless you had it backed up somewhere
else you're screwed
yeah I had mine backed up fortunately
all the other Drive yeah but they wiped
out my music library yeah and the only
thing left was things I had purchased
from that yep
that's that's that's it they wiped
everything else out there's and that
that that whole business model of you
don't own anything I mean markers
Microsoft does it does well they didn't
work they did the same thing to me on
wouldn't work on office yeah wiped out
on my clipart Oh on it was a it was an
office program I had purchased yeah
which had clipart
in the software yeah they wiped out all
my clipart yeah it was like we have
control of this you don't yeah and then
I think to go back to this I think part
of what's because we look at it we're
like this is [ __ ] you know they're
gonna but that's because we have this
this more traditional consumption of
intellectual property they want us to
accept the notion that no no no you get
everything you need from us yeah and
let's put it all up on the cloud we'll
take care of you
yeah that's exactly the but the attitude
yeah I saw a very interesting thing the
other day where somebody had said in
2009 people are like let's put things in
the cloud
that way we won't lose it you know when
our home computer crashes and now people
are like putting things on their home
computer so they won't lose it when the
cloud takes it away I still know people
who are putting it on the cloud I have
never trusted it that media I have never
trusted the cloud for everything yeah
yeah well let's let's talk about it so
other technology that comes up in this
there's a nice phrase that that this guy
Michelle Foucault had technology of the
self I mean he wasn't talking about
something that he's like creating
himself he was actually talking about
things in ancient philosophy that would
allow us to transform our own minds
essentially what happens in good
psychotherapy right but was also
happening in philosophy done as a way of
life by the Stoics or the Epicurious or
plata nests also happened a spiritual
direction you use your own resources to
work upon yourself so visualization
exercises and Hawksley
he you know he got that sort of thing
less from Western philosophy and more
from Hinduism and Buddhist practices
because there that was an integral part
of you know what was going on he was
part of the Vedanta Society and so in
the island novel that's an integral part
of things they they're very pragmatic
they they realize that some Buddhist
mindfulness techniques will be nowadays
called mindfulness and hypnotism and a
couple other things could be used by
people not just to work on other people
but to work on themselves as well and
there you've got more more autonomy
everybody in the island is except for
the the new Rajah who's driven by his
his desires
and the reporter of course who's like an
outsider is aiming at autonomy that's
completely missing and brave right now
that's not there in Haven essence either
they're just driven by that the wish to
defeat it you know the enemy and I guess
you could say a desire for security you
know but in the island that's part of
what makes it even Opia there's there's
a rather fortuitous combination of
Mahayana Buddhism and a kind of
hard-nosed Western rationalism that
recognizes that the body can't a body
and mind can be affected by the things
that we do with it
that get fused together and become their
way of life focus on maximizing your
actualization yeah rather than economic
maximization yeah yeah in holding
individual capacities yeah and
recognizing that as a value I mean you
can't do that unless that's actually not
just recognized but taken seriously so
you get all these businesses right now
that are pushing mindfulness like big
corporations that are like we want our
employees to be happy you know yeah well
now why do they want them to be happy
it's so that they're they're better at
doing the the tasks that are set to them
and they don't complain as much and
they're they're not you know like cogs
that are you know slipping every once in
a while that's not a good reason to do
mindfulness as a matter of fact that
takes mindfulness and turns it in
essentially into a tool of social
control I think there's also an element
of mindfulness ties to some health
issues in terms that's true too yeah and
it keeps keeps the insurance down yeah
and you're not taking a seat please
yeah that's sure more productive
employee yeah and it's not easily
defined either so mindfulness oh he's
gotten a little better yeah I was first
becoming
I bet the buzzword yeah I would like
ascendancy bark and stuff like that
almost anything right now there's three
of us Missouri but could mean something
something that each of us yeah you know
it was became almost became almost a
joke for a little while I know my moves
are some other crap that'll keep people
calm we were in this study at the
Culinary Institute of America
and it was poorly designed but it was
with the heart it was with Harvard Sam
Wiley Institute and and culinary was
pairing up and here's that here's the
basic idea if you adopt a holistic
approach it was about in a reducing
obesity and increasing health amount
among employees if you take a holistic
approach and provide fat people with
tools that they need in order to get get
you know better in their life then
adding these different you know
modalities together is going to produce
a better effect now they didn't do any
controlled studies or anything like that
the only things that they actually did
is a few assess you know a few of those
inventories mostly from the positive
psychology people and they did like
complete blood work on us and all that
sort of stuff what they gave well here's
what the components were so there were
their cooking classes led by
professional chefs on healthy eating how
to substitute you know quinoa for this
and that how to make it taste good you
know and then they would give us you
know some some samples we ultimately you
know had some training in the kitchen
and that was that was pretty good and
then there was a free membership to a
health club which we couldn't use
unfortunately because it was on the
wrong side of the river from where we
lived so I only went in there like three
times a life coach and you know I think
that might have been helpful for some
people but when you're in that kind of
line of work yourself
he's getting the stick from somebody
who's not quite as good at it that not
very helpful either
and then there was one other component
and then there was mindfulness training
and it was by this this lady who was
like the prototypical hippy mindfulness
instructor you know flowing you know
clothes and stuff like that the soft
noise all that and so she would come in
and she would do exercises and there are
very simple things I like to raise and
exercise do you both know that so you
like get the raisin first you smell it
look at it you're mindful about that you
taste it you just touch your tongue to
it this is a good thing to do actually
did you know I'm teaching a class on
philosophy and mindfulness and the
philosophies of ways of life and I did
this with my students with gummy bears
instead of raisins and they loved it you
know and it's good to like you know
savor your food and all that but she did
this and she did other exercises too
like visualization exercises and
relaxation exercises what she's doing
with these type a people from the
Culinary Institute of America she
actually made many of them anxious by
having them do mindfulness exercise
which is the exact opposite effect of
what what she was you know aiming at she
was like you know stunned haha why you
know you people are doing it right yeah
and then the director of this study he
couldn't resist using the word mindful
for everything and after a while it was
so cheapened they were like oh my god is
this guy gonna say mindfulness again you
know and I think it probably wound up
turning a lot of people off from what
what could be good for them if somebody
they had a good mindfulness instructor
it might be helpful for them but the
most those people will probably never do
it interestingly the study was a
complete flop people became diabetic
over the course of this this study
people gained weight
people's numbers went up
and you know Andy has a great take on it
you're gonna take a bunch of fat people
and put them in a you know after work in
a theater where there's you know being
taught about food what do you think
they're gonna do after that I mean we
went up we went yeah we went to Olive
Garden after you know unless you
actually have something better
structured thing in place it doesn't
doesn't work but it's you know the same
sort of idea social experimentation for
the good right ostensibly in this case
it wasn't very well thought out and it
wasn't well administered I would say
well yeah 80s in corporations there was
a trend yes for providing fitness
centers in the building yeah that's true
for children on the site I mean the
daycare is probably a good in general
not bad ideas yeah but there was a trend
there in the mid eighties yeah - late
80s and the idea was really based on
making people more productive getting
more yeah maybe out of the workforce you
don't do it was there were health things
tied to it as things tied to it and all
sorts of things but nobody really ever
studied it to make sure it really was
something that was gonna work just as a
side note about that I don't think I
would want to workout in the place where
I work because I wouldn't want to be in
there with my boss you know or somebody
like that like checking up on me and
seeing what I'm doing and I imagine a
lot of other people probably wouldn't
like it to where they were they
well-used know when you get this you've
got a group of 880 workers okay you know
dreamin yeah yeah how much how often do
you think they're going to take an hour
out of our day
yeah that's trying to go work well you
could get them to compete with each
other
you could then they'd have to shower and
yeah people would these they what we
didn't do it even if it was available
the only people who use
in my case the building I was working in
the only people who used it were the
slackers no we had it was the federal
government okay we have in law
enforcement people oh okay and they had
like a sick boss well they had to pass
fitness tests very good basis yeah so
they have a different motivation for
staying fit yeah then the rest of that
everybody else did that makes sense
and everybody else were tied days yeah
other majority no number quite a few of
us retirees we weren't taken you know
another thing I wanted to get out of
this as well that I see as a theme that
comes up is well there are two things
one is how can a society see itself
accurately in brave new world it's that
Monde guy right the controller he
controls one-tenth of the world he's
that's a convenient character to have in
the narrative because he can say here's
what we're doing and all that in brave
new in 1984 by contrast what was the
name of the guy who winced and you know
he he was wondering like it essentially
initiates him and says this is you know
what we do worthy leads I mean you know
he can he can give them insight into
what's going on but most people only see
what their little part now the character
John right he's an outsider so he can be
useful for saying this is this why are
you doing things this way it doesn't
have to be that way yep that's a useful
plot device and and you know that you
mentioned the Highland story
I'm blanking out and again myself
stranger stranger and strangely I want
to say strange new world that I knew
that was
again the same thing you've got the guy
who's the Martian he can say oh it's so
weird that you do things this way here's
how we do things right and I think
that's kind of a standard device in
utopian literature yeah that's right
that's the main character who's the guy
who tortures the guy who tells him the
how things really are I think so but in
any case you know how can society
actually see itself accurately in the
island the inhabitants of the island
they they actually do know what's going
on with them and you've got an outsider
coming in who's having everything
explained to him but there isn't any
sort of like they you know the
individual lower people can't really see
the the big view so it's a different
kind of utopia in ape and essence none
of the characters in the actual ape in
essence part you could say have a real
vision about what their what their world
is like all right they're all sort of
trapped within their their perspectives
and then you can you can also say this
on an individual level one of the things
Hawks Lee was concerned with is what is
our real identity or what is our true
self how do we discover that how do we
learn who we are and so he thought that
you know non-western philosophy Hinduism
Buddhism in particular were avenues for
that not that Western philosophy
couldn't contribute to that and he
thought that certain certain drug use
could also contribute to that when he
wrote the doors of perception he got a
lot of flack for
from religious people particularly
religious people from Hinduism and
Buddhism because he was suggesting that
maybe enlightenment or release or
liberation was something that could be
aided by by use of these psychotropic
drugs and they were like that is totally
the wrong way to do things you are
setting yourself behind no I mean
Buddhism does have one of the five
precepts is not to use essentially
mind-altering substances but they did
the reaction was very strong you know
I'm saying that that was that was not
the thing to do well yeah on that topic
they weighed in but how do we get to
know who our true self is that you
talked about self realization in the
island right so they they talk about
that explicitly and say you know you
can't discover you can't you can't just
sort of like happen upon your true self
you have to work at it and so kind of
it's a continual process and the guy
forget the character's name in the
island of English yeah that's his name
far far to be he's kind of you know he's
a really damaged case so he would have
to do an awful lot to to do that but he
starts making progress towards that
partly through his conversations with
people and working through some of the
traumas of his life and partly through
eventually the use of the function drug
by the time he does that the invasion of
the island is happening and
and you know the the fun time is over I
guess but you know so it's a much more
optimistic view of things
but in a way it's not because it does
end right and so this raises another
interesting issue
I mean Huxley himself as a pacifist can
you have let's say you could have a
utopia you know somehow there you'd have
people who aren't so screwed up they're
not going to they're not going to piss
it away somehow by making the wrong
decisions can they actually defend
themselves against the rest of the world
or not or is it inevitable that any sort
of better place that gets created as
sooner or later you're going to get get
corrupted and made part of the same
system surrounding it yeah they're going
to just take it yeah yeah cuz you know
it's not an issue of not having enough
food or anything like that they've
they've got all those sort of things
figured out they they generate a surplus
for other nearby countries they have
enough power they have enough other
resources they don't know the outside
knows they're easy pickings yeah
especially because they have all of that
it's like oh let's go take it yeah I
mean so do you have to have something
like a militia or I mean you think about
like why nobody ever screws with
Switzerland it's because you know they
all have guns yeah certain required to
have every citizen carries a gun a
sobriety carry gun well they're yeah
they have in their locker they're also
required to do military service
and you know yet military that's true
yeah but citizens are all considered
part of the military yeah I mean is that
the only way to do it to keep keep the
outside world from coming in and taking
over if you scale up to a larger
landmass will it still work
that's yeah that's that's that's a
perennial problem in question again you
know Rousseau is somebody and and we
talked about Plato Plato also talks
about this issue so like in Plato's
ideal Republic the city can't get too
big because if it does the people don't
know each other and and so you couldn't
have something like an empire size and
pull it off Rousseau thinks that
anything bigger than like a swiss canton
not going to be a good government I
don't know and maybe this was where like
the the promise of technology if we
could harness that without you know like
automatically giving everything away to
Facebook or Google or Microsoft or
Amazon or whoever maybe that could be an
equalizer but I think most of us don't
don't know how to use technology right
you know uh you know I was joking with I
don't know if I brought this up before I
was joking with my students I think at
the beginning of the semester I said
imagine if like aliens came here to
earth they're an advanced civilization
they're like wow you guys have
discovered nuclear power and oh you've
got the Internet you know and you've got
these you've got these you know
microcomputers and you've got them all
linked together so they can do these
really incredible massive jobs and
there's server farms to handle all your
data what are you using it for you no
way you'd be like well the SETI program
you know that's how we found you they'd
be level that's cool but let's actually
take a look under the hood and you know
the the two biggest sucks of data I bet
they would discovered porn and video
games you know
what the hell and nuclear weapons are
the design required a lot of computing
power no but just taking nuclear power
what are we oh I'm turning it into
nuclear weapon yeah that I rather than
like providing safe power for everybody
but I just that I think the aliens would
look at us to be like this race is
stupid you know they all they do they're
interested in like yeah games where
people are you know shooting each other
or maybe like creating you know like The
Sims where they're creating a fake life
and doing that sort of thing or people
screwing you know that's that seems to
be what they've done most you know with
their their resources socialism let's
true yeah
and safety nets for people and they're
not perfect yeah they've got problems
they've got their own problems yeah yeah
but then you look around them and all
the countries that are not really doing
that yeah well I mean Tennessee not to
be willing to learn yeah from other
experiences I I saw it in business if
you moved from Wisconsin to Alabama yeah
and said oh well why don't we try this
because it worked for us up here yeah
it's like oh is that work for us down
there right no we're not doing that
yeah we ran into it plant to plant state
to state an interesting there's a
resistance yeah for whatever reason
there's a resistance and I broke words
go with this is the maybe the way to
achieve an actual functioning utopia
yeah is to build on other people's
success to build right up not to try to
have it all at once not to have it all
the once but to evolve it that's what
they did in the island
right yeah try to live all of it yeah
and except in the island the people
around them didn't do it right it's
gotta be larger I see so you're saying
is that you
you'd have to like defuse it to other
other groups like if somebody could
learn from this program in Sweden or
this program in Germany or whatever yeah
or this program here you know it's just
if you could learn from each other and
build from if we could you know develop
that ability to build from those things
yeah might we might be able to evolve it
I mean it's interesting because all the
big tech companies had that sort of
vision for like how their product was
gonna change everything for the better
you know but they almost never thought
things through they were there unduly
optimistic about like people's compare I
think about Twitter for example right
some of the most it's not the most toxic
platform maybe read it can also be said
to be quite toxic but if you want to get
into arguments with people it's a great
place to do so you can have people call
me all sorts of names toxic I wasn't
thinking on 4chan age yeah and the stuff
that sort of like almost like it's very
toxic yeah where it's off of the
mainstream but the Twitter's like
mainstream toxicity and you know the
designers of Twitter I don't think they
thought oh yeah this is this is where
we're heading you know and even even
today they still won't acknowledge just
how toxic it is you know and how
arbitrary their their monitoring systems
are content yeah
well they've been doing that too facto
for a while now it's just how the open
yeah yeah yeah not even trying yes I
think one of this is gonna sound dark
okay could be good sounder no we're
talking about dystonia so I've I think
the the fact that we all have individual
free will is probably the biggest
barrier to creating a utopia okay I
think you're right because what I would
find to be a utopia might be very
different or similar to what you might
find it will you might find and that's
gonna be a long-ass kill if this is
thousand people yes there's gonna be at
least 200 different flavors of utopia
with one other that's why that's why you
get the division yeah like you were
saying earlier well we just said you
know well my view of what's this yeah I
mean one way to shave it to shave it
down as you say okay listen there's
gonna be like options but it's from a
limited list to decide
well that's Lucas's assignment options
are personal and weaponry so utopia
nobody has weapons some people's idea
you don't do this and if somebody is
resolutely anti-violent anti weaponry
yeah they're not it's not going to be
utopia for them if they have to go to
mandatory training sessions to learn how
to use weapons if they're there then
great wired carry and on the other hand
if you're someone who was raised in a
hunting family and grandpa handed down
his rifle and now this utopia comes
along it says nobody gets weapons you're
gonna be miserable you're gonna feel
attacked and isolated and shame and yeah
I'm gonna be utopian we could say
similar things about like food
consumption ya know just about anything
I mean we share anything the only thing
we probably share is the rate of oxygen
we take as long as the individualism and
you see that in brave new world with the
island external yeah we put all the A's
on aquas on island well there's that one
character how Holtz Watson right who
seems to be well-adjusted he's an alpha
right he's that writer and he's cool
with being exiled so he has a good
outcome because of that yeah he's okay
about going to an island yeah because he
knows that he's gonna he's gonna and
somebody have a better life Bernard is
resentful about it
right that's because he's been
conditioned to believe that this life is
the right yeah yeah well even the guy in
charge was tough on us now yeah he
admits that as a scientist he had he
chosen dividual t yeah in order to have
the power yeah it was a choice and he
made he was that conditioned to do it
that's that's just yeah I mean that is a
similar choice that many people in power
not in our you know not in Utopia but in
our actual world here they're they're
constantly facing think about our
politicians we've got all these people
running for office they have to be
almost like totally squeaky-clean at
this point because anything that that
they've done can come up they don't have
to care about about nothing's we clean
some can get away with it you know
they've been part of the establishment
for a while but like new candidates well
are people like you were talking about
in that environment you were in people
who think they're better than everybody
no matter what yeah then basically
narcissus people who think the rules
don't apply to me yeah I'm wealthier
than everybody else or I'm better than
everybody else whatever they don't care
if there's dirt in their closet they do
what other people bring it out of there
confronted don't care yeah I've been
some don't but I've quite a few seem to
they usually care for the wrong reasons
they're like well this diminishes my
prestige in a hurts me yeah yeah if
they're saying they're saying mean
things about me yeah yeah well you know
one of the things I was talking with
another of my class today was the it was
apologies and the I think it was United
that the the doctor got dragged off of
by the Shekhar
yeah yeah and I think it was you but you
have a lot of problems yeah the biggest
problem I mean to begin with if that guy
if that the president of United wanted
to throw the the CPD under the bus he
could have because technically the
United people didn't drag the the you
know 70 year old doctor off of the plane
it was the airport police and they are
Chicago police so he could have said hey
what do you expect from these brutal you
know people look at the stuff they do
all the time you know but he didn't do
that instead first he started saying
well he should have cooperated and then
people are like you're getting it wrong
and then he's like let's try this again
we're really sorry that you tried to
basically we're mistakes were made we're
sorry you feel bad about this the again
people are like this guy doesn't get it
you know and it took a long time for him
to come around and say we're really
sorry for the bad customer service we're
looking into this and by then yeah
nobody believes them for anything well
and IA I imagine that he probably
personally was bothered by all of this
but he's not bothered because the gut if
he if he was decent human being he
would've been bothered by seeing the
footage and being like holy crap this is
not supposed to happen
we got to do something about this he was
bothered by the fact that the stock
price went down you know and it made him
look stupid and people were like on
Twitter saying look at this guy you know
can you believe his BS you know he
didn't like that so you know it did
affect him but for the wrong reasons you
know so yeah well what else is there to
to I you know all the philosophical
themes I was thinking about bringing up
I've managed to get in is there anything
that either of you want to
yeah when Huxley was born at the turn of
the century yeah in some of our past
authors we found that some of their
beliefs or feelings or motivations
either at the time we're already
considered antisocial or have with the
changing of our times become completely
unacceptable I think yeah okay Lovecraft
yeah the racism yeah yeah even Mark
Twain is one of my favorite authors I'm
using an word he uses recent language
that today would not apply language at
that time that's what I'm getting at is
or even more contemporarily because he's
got card and this is anti intellectual
yeah it's very vocal opposition and is
there anything like that with hooks to
that has changed with the times that
came up in your research where now we
would say oh that's kind of unsavory
mm-hmm I mean not that I not that I've
seen maybe a brave new world the role of
the women as being sexual toys basically
yeah okay that's that kind of stuff
interests me because we're always as a
society whether we know it or not
whether we like it or not we're always
evolving and changing
[Music]
you